c'est le grand jour pour tout les
majorettes de france à saint cyr l'école
1200 adeptes de la discipline au bâton
était réuni pour l'année elle
championnat national parmi les troupes
celle de la ville menée par graziella
aussi membré du jury
elle a dû noter l'ensemble la
chorégraphie le bâton la technique la
partie sa part la participation des
petites aussi parce que l'on prend pas
que les meilleurs on prend aussi à
tourner toute la troupe
cette année pourrait laisser picchu
comme elle les appelle c'est l'espagne
alors tenue folklorique rouge et noir et
surtout pas et charbonneau sont de
rigueur à quelques minutes du passage la
monitrice donne les dernières consignes
à droite on sourit quand il faut qu'on
fasse on regarde les gens ont fait le
regard des gens en allemagne à juba même
voilà on n'oublie pas les manières
soirée le derby c'est parti pour une
danse de trois minutes en musique avec
le traditionnel bâton mais aussi des
éventails de foulards et des drapeaux
non
retour en coulisses la pression
redescend et les réfections s'entraîne
donc c'est pas tout à fait bien
et là et c'était beaucoup mieux très
satisfaite je pense qu'on a assuré quand
même le public était là on a bien danser
les filles sont amusés c'est le
principal et elles sont récompensées
grand prix ruban d'honneur félicitations
du jury et même haute distinction
moins de chance avec la météo
l'après-midi les démonstrations ont été
écourtées ou l majoré de saint cyr
viennent rendez vous pour leur gala le
1er juin